Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcasts for
Monday. Um,
December 5th, 2016 what's going on?
Our y? Yeah. Um, you're doing your holiday shopping.
Is that what you're doing? Oh my God. What do I get this person?
And it's just not enough time. Slide a bullet. By the way.
Slight Ebola is still left. Um, yeah. Uh, you guys are,
you're in the same boat as me. Um, you know,
I handled some of the shit I needed to handle. Uh, you know,
I go fucking nieces and nephews and all this shit I gotta take care of,
so I don't know what to do. You know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to go on bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page and click on the Amazon link and go straight to Amazon
and kicked me a little dope, right, baby, Huh? Oh No. Bill, you shouldn't have.
Hey, don't worry about it. I made a little bit of fucking Kashi. Shaun,
this one. Oh, enjoy your remote control.
Labra d. Um, anyways, uh,
so I know the podcast is late. I was going to try to do it last night, but, uh,
unfortunately I had to go to a memorial service for my friend who died. And, uh,
it was a beautiful, beautiful ceremony.
And also one of the saddest things I've ever seen with these young kids and
everything. And, uh, didn't feel too funny last night, but, um,
I learned a lot, man. I learned a lot by going to that service.
I will tell you that because when they did the collage of his life in the end of
it, um, the,
the photos and the videos and everything,
like 99% of it was about him with his wife and being a dad.
So it made me feel lucky that I'm going to become a father. Definitely. Because,
uh, I was thinking like, what if I died right now?
What would the collage look like for me?
And it would just be a picture of me and a bunch of different comedy clubs
making weird faces. Um, obviously the lovely DHEA, but you know what I mean?
I was Kinda like, uh, what me playing drums? Like,
what the fuck did I do to keep, you know,
not to say that you have to have a fucking kid.
Cause definitely I think if you don't have a kid at this point,
if you don't want to,
that's a great fucking thing considering all the shit going on with the
environment to not just have another person, just to have a person.
But um, you know, like with all of these things,
the great thing was I got to see a bunch of comics that I had not seen in awhile
and uh,
I will be seeing a bunch more this Tuesday night at the a laugh factory.
I believe the event is sold out.
So thank you to everybody that came down and bought tickets.
I A or however the fuck you kids do it nowadays. I really appreciate it.
It's going to be a, the money is going to be going to a is a twin boys.
But um, anyway, so yes, I went to, I was a very, very heavy emotional nights,
so I did not feel remotely funny because that was the thing. Oh,
typical fucking psycho comic.
I'm going to go to a memorial service for a friend of mine that I've known for
almost 25 years. And then I'll come home. Then I'll do my after that, you know,
if you think some of my shit is bleak and dark, um, yeah.
I, I'm glad I did not record last night, so I had some shit to do this morning.
I'm a little bit late. I'm,
we're editing the season two of f is for family and all that shit.
Have I made you laugh yet?
All I'm doing is telling you what an album laid in my bed and I bucked it, blah,
blah, blah, you know, fully clothed by the way,
fully clothed this episode. Um, the NC 17,
Thursday afternoon, just before Friday,
Monday morning podcasts did not do well in the ratings as far as the feedback.
You know,
it was something that we here at Monday morning podcast industry's decided was,
you know, maybe a different flavor.
We could throw the podcast every once in a while I could just be wearing a robe
with nothing underneath it that Nia could then comment on. And, um, you know,
it was like new coke. That's, that's what I would say.
I'm kidding actually with some of the funniest fucking photoshops I don't know
if you guys saw them on Twitter. Uh,
the Sharon Stone was fucking f that was, I dunno how you taught that one.
That was great. So anyways, let's, let's talk about life.
Talk about the world. Let's talk about uh, hey,
congratulations to everybody up there.
And the code is that was fighting against the pipeline.
Evidently they've been able at least able to stop it for now. You know.
Good Lord. Some of the shit that they were saying,
those corporations with doin man, they were playing for keeps,
they were saying at nighttime they had drones and they were coming in,
they had this pepper spray water mixture they were spraying at the protesters.
Um, that whole thing is so fucked up cause I was just like,
why can't they just go down to home depot and buy some of those fucking things
that makes the pipe make a 90 degree turn,
go up the street a little bit and go around the shit. Um,
evidently all the white towns, the cowboy side,
I guess they try to go through other people's towns and they were like, yeah,
you're never running that shit through here.
So even the white people didn't want it. I Dunno.
I guess what I'm saying is I should have bought a Tesla, um,
until they do the research and what those fucking batteries do once they finally
take those out. You know,
I remember Michael Jordan telling me not to throw out my batteries, you know,
I believe he was standing next to the children. That's so together. Sneakers,
there's so much, you know, you can never,
you can never not get mud on your shoes no matter what you do. Like,
how the fuck do you just like, no matter what you're doing,
I do this and I'm not hurting anybody or the planet.
Just the mere fact that you're fucking here, you know,
somebody is crying in factory somewhere, right? Or the inverse,
if you're the kid or the person working in the sweatshop, right.
You gotta be doing something, you've probably taken it home with you, you know,
coming home, screaming at your wife.
That's my part of the cockpit flat asleep on right. There's something.
Who the fuck knows? I Dunno. Maybe I'm just an arrogant con first world country.
I have no idea. But let's talk about Formula One racing here. Everybody.
Nico Rosberg Dude, level of fucking drama.
Like ladies, if you ever wanted to get into a sport, but you just find,
you know,
the four major ones in the u s boring or you're not into soccer or whatever the
fuck people watch around the world. Cricket, you like drama.
You like all of that shit.
I highly suggest watching formula one racing this whole Nico Rosberg Lewis
Hamilton thing. Nico Rosberg, right? He's the, he's the upstart guys.
I said he finally won his first championship after being a bridesmaid the last
couple of years. This is my first year watching it.
So I'm sure a lot of this shit I'll have wrong. Um,
he wins his first championship. All right?
And then out of fucking nowhere out of the fucking blue,
he retired. He just said, that's it. I'm done.
And somebody tweeted that to me.
So I looked it up and I saw that it was true and the only clip I saw was him
just standing there and his wife was talking to the entire fucking time.
So I'm just sitting there looking, going like, wait a minute, is this guy,
was this her decision? You know, he's got a kid on the way, just like, God,
thank God you really have to drive again this weekend where
I sit. It's just so silly. I mean, you know, I drive a car to, you know,
I don't have to put a number on it and drive around s turns. I just,
it's just such a male testosterone thing.
You're hurting the environment.
I don't know if he got in her ear like the whole fucking Yoko thing,
which people always says, Yoko broke up the Beatles, which I, I don't,
I don't believe that.
I think John and Paul kept bringing their work home,
bitching about one another. And after a while, both Linda and Yoko were like,
Hey, well why don't you just quit? I mean, you're not happy. Right?
And then they just threw that out there and then they're ego. You know,
like they would call them their bluff. They couldn't be like, what?
But there would, I,
I don't know if I could write without him. Right. So they just, they,
they couldn't do that. So they just fucking,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about. Let's get back to the,
let's get back to the race in here.
So I didn't know if it was that version and then I read that, uh,
what's his face? That was a Kiki Lotto or whatever he was trashing.
Nico Rosberg said he made them look silly and stupid and all of that.
And I'm just sitting there, why the fuck would this guy quit 31 years old.
You just won your first one. Now you're going to walk away.
You know what, why would you do that?
And then I was thinking maybe it's his wife, he's got a kid coming along.
He just wanted, he was very emotional.
He had to come down afterwards within this,
the little bit of a melancholy slash depression. And then you're like, fuck,
now I've got to do this again, and you gotta climb back up the mountain again.
I don't think it's, you know what I think it is? I think that, um,
Louis Hamilton was the favorite son. This is,
that's just total fucking guests at Mercedes.
He sick of dealing with that dynamic, you know?
Yeah.
And he wanted to get out of his fucking contract and the only way out was to
retire. So he might leave for, I don't know how long.
Okay.
You know, and then he'll come back with a different team.
There's no fucking way. He's not coming back 31 years old.
There's no fucking way he's not coming back. He's going to take a year off,
get his kid up and running, you know,
get the kid to be able to use the fucking shit. Right.
Mama Dadda throttle break, right. You get it.
Say a few fucking words and then he's going to be right back out there again.
You know,
I think he's going to be out there and he's going to race for a different team.
But here's the thing though,
those Mercedes cars were so fucking good that all they had to do was just get to
the first turn. We, whoever won the first term, right?
One the Goddamn race had seen. So I'm going to guess,
I'm going to guess he's going to go with the red bull team.
Cause that was the only other team that seemed to fucking win anything this year
as far as the shit that I watched. But uh, Jesus Christ.
So Nico's getting fucking trashed people like what the fuck?
Five reasons why you would quit. Um,
Kiki Rosberg calls him a contracepting something key league. Niki Lauda.
Sorry Kiki. Nikki clot. I'm like combining names here.
Slams Nico Rosberg for making Mercedes look dumb dude.
In that last race with Lewis Hamilton,
slow down because if Nico Rosberg came in fourth place or worse,
Lewis would've won the championship.
So he deliberately slowed the fuck down to let the third and fourth place guys
catch up. And um,
and then he disobeyed a direct order from his fucking pit crew. This is,
I'm telling you, it's fucking top gun. You know, you do.
Characters are going to top gun, right? And He,
they tell him to speed up and Louis was like, Nah, yeah, I'm good.
I can still win this race.
Let's just fucking add 40 years of stress to this fucking guy. Maybe he'll,
he'll spin out now when, and I'm,
yeah.
Rosberg's also talked about sometimes, you know when they're out on the track,
he doesn't know how far Lewis is going to go.
Is he going to push me off the track? But prospect's done the same shit.
He did that like twice.
He has his fucking move where he goes into a turn and it's like go straight for
way too long and then oops at the last second turns away and drive some guy into
the gravel. Oh Geez. Belt. You don't know anything about this sport, do you? Um,
yeah,
I dunno. We'll see what the fuck happens. But that's my call.
I think he's gonna stay home for a year with this kid. Right.
He's going to go out of his fucking mind.
As much as he's gonna love his kids much.
He's going to love wife the entire time that Kenny Loggins song is going to be
going on in the background. Well,
what did you do? Did do fucking substance up? Did do, but deputy,
but though
he been, I ain't in Bernie now.
Right. Um, what about John at JFK said,
and then the guy in the fucking pumps said, he said, I am a,
I am an egg or I'm a cookie or something. Yeah,
it's going to drive them up the fucking wall and he's going to have to go back
out there again and uh, you know,
and then I think he's going to drive for the rest of his fucking career. Um,
that's my guess. All right. So there you go. There's a whole bunch of shit.
How often do you hear a bunch of Formula One talk on a fucking American podcast?
You know, not that I go fuck yourself. Hey, how about that Patriots Rams Game?
You know, that's tremendous. If anybody ever had trouble sleeping,
that would have been a great game to fucking watch Jesus Christ.
I actually did. I actually watched the,
you got to watch the game live with me on Facebook.
It was something last second. We decided to try and all things comedy.
So thank you for the 1500 people or so that tuned in and watched me watch the
game. I'm sure they'll put together some sort of clips from that.
Um, [inaudible]
so if you guys like it enough, if it gets enough hits, I might start doing that.
I want to do it for boring fucking games because if the game matters,
you're not gonna want to listen to me talking. But patriots first rams,
that's a good one. Right? And all I do is I just do the first half.
Um,
so anyways, I might do it with Joe Bark, nick or somebody like that.
Maybe with Paul Versey at some point we'll figure it out. So anyways,
so I have to go to this, um, memorial service. Um,
last night I was so proud of my friend that, you know,
I could really see what a great husband and father he was.
So I already knew the suit that I was gonna wear. Cause you,
when you get to my age, you know, it's fucking sucks man.
You start losing people and you have your funeral soon. You know,
for a lot of people it was,
I'm going to a wedding suit and then that big as you get older than they come.
So I'm going to a funeral. Fucking sucks. So, um,
you remember last year I got into the best shape of my fucking life and I went
to put on the suit that I fucking bought during that time.
Jesus Christ,
I could barely get the pants on and I couldn't wear a tie to the event cause I
couldn't get the shirt closed and all I did, I put on like 15 fucking pounds.
It's like how skinny was I?
And I was just sitting there screaming at myself in the mirror. My mother, my,
uh, I know my mother always told me when I was, you know,
she was always like fucking, I don't know,
she was always honest about not being fat fuck kids, which is hilarious to me.
Cause who wants a fat fuck for a kid? Right?
So I'm sitting there screaming at myself in the mirror, right. And, uh,
my wife is just sitting there fucking laughing her ass off at me.
I would go look at you, love your fucking discuss me.
Just just completely trashing myself cause that's how I get myself back into
shape. So, um,
I remember I mentioned last podcast that I was going to do a half hour cardio
every fucking day this month cause I'm not putting on the pigs in a blanket
fucking apple strudel. What's a good Christmas goose? What do you have?
What do you, what do people have? Chinese food. The Jewish people, right?
What's the shit that everybody fucking eats this month makes you a fat fuck?
All of this stuff. The pies, the cookies, the Christmas party, the bows,
all of that shit. You end up putting on all this fucking weight.
Then what happens? Everybody joins a fucking gym.
Everybody joins the gym in January. Right? And it's just fucking mobbed.
Right?
And all you gotta do is just hang in there too about the second week of February
and everybody just starts dropping off like the Bataan death march or some shit.
Right? That's such a fucked up reference.
But I've been watching a lot of world war two shit probably even said it wrong.
They say baton, like what? Your twirl, the Bataan death march.
It was a bunch of high school bands that had to walk to the prom that none of
them have dates to. Oh, you have to be that me and you know what?
I don't, but it's funny, isn't it? Isn't it?
Um, anyways, so you know, it's great.
Why don't you beat the fucking new person to the gym rush?
Why don't you do yourself a favor and not go into the new year, 1520,
30, 40 50 pounds overweight. Let's say you knocked that numbered number.
What's that first number? Huh? Unless you're in triple digits, I,
you know, I don't want to fucking give you to him, but if he,
if he got a double digit figure you're trying to lose,
let's say you're 20 pounds overweight,
why don't you try to get that two down to a one, you know,
get that 18 down to a fucking nine. Get that 20 down to a 10.
Just knock it down. Run some fucking miles off. You fucking Oh,
domino, right? Come on. Admit it. Good. Nobody's looking.
Nobody's looking at cubicle. Reached out, reached down, grab, grab a handful.
I look at you, Huh? That's still, that's what you're gonna do.
You're going to add to that Jesus Christ. Come on, say it with me.
I'm a fat cunt, right? Just say it. One, two, three.
I'm a fat cunt. All right?
Then the first thing you got to do is, is,
is admitting it to yourself and you've lost control over so many of those
fucking Christmas cookies. But let's be honest,
they don't really taste that good.
A lot of them are bad shortbread with some shitty frosting and some sprinkles on
it, right? You don't need that shit. Right? Half Hour,
half hour every day. Make a God damn playlist.
You know what's funny is I've actually, because I'm so dreading doing cardio,
rather than listening to some testosterone aggressive shit,
like I actually was listening to like Paul Simon,
like my cardio thing starts off with something so right by Paul Simon,
which were you really listened to that song? I should look up the fucking I.
My Internet doesn't work down here. The fucking lyrics are really annoying.
He's like, when something goes wrong, I'm the first to admit it.
Okay.
Um, the first two ed made it, but the last one to know, Whoa, whoa.
Right. So He's already said like, you know, hey,
if there's something wrong like I, I'm the first one to admit it.
I just never know what that is. I don't know if it Yale,
fuck you Paul Simon, you can't,
I hate when people do that. You know what I mean? They just, they know,
they fucking say that they're an asshole and then they take no responsibility
for it because hey man, I, I just don't, it's hard for me.
It's just like hard for me to tell when I'm being a total selfish dose.
Who? My Paul, you know that. Okay.
Yeah.
If you could do a fucking sound check. Okay.
And you can hear that the horns are too far down in the mix.
You can't tell me that you can't be in a car with somebody else and not hear
that you're being a fucking asshole, you know?
And then the rest of it is when something goes right. Oh,
it's like you lose me. It's apt to confuse me. Like he's just like, oh,
let's all stop and help Paul Simon. You know,
that's why he married Daddy. But cal, I'm telling Ya. You know what I mean?
No fucking broad. His Age was going to put up with his horse shit.
He had a g etic find some young chick that was still fucking wide. I, you know,
slightly confused.
Here's what I am is what was your Warren? What were your right?
She didn't know what the fuck she don't know which way was up. Right.
God Damn oversized sweater walking, walking around.
He fucking shows up. Like, you know, I mean, have you, if something goes wrong,
I'm the first to admit it. But yeah, I never seem to know.
I'm like the last guy to know. Paul, you're a nice person.
I like see, you know, he's behind her just banging away.
It's fucking to pay. Slap it off the back of his head. Right.
That's how the whole fucking thing went down. And in the meantime,
he killing the new Bohemians, right? That you know, for a pop band.
I mean those guys could play. Greg Guitars did a great fucking drummer.
And what happened? Fuck it.
Paul Simon comes up with this hat and hand showing up. You know Paul Simon got,
he got hair plugs right after.
I think Elton John and Elton John got the original ones. So like, you know,
his head was so scarred up. That's why when he was real cooked up in the 80s,
he was wearing like those mannequin wigs because I don't,
I know what I'm talking about. I think that was I at the grocery store in red.
A few too many US magazines. Um,
yeah.
And it's all, how the fuck that again. Oh, we're talking about working out.
Okay. Maria,
to talk about Paul Simon Edis fucking relationship I think overstepped a few
here, especially during this holiday month. So I apologize. All right,
so I start with that, then I go into one trick pony.
Then I go 50 ways to, to a,
to leave you a lama with Steve Gadd on drums.
Um, oh by the way, he's coming to town with the fucking Eric Clapton.
Somebody offered me a fucking ticket and I forgot to get back to him.
I gotta say I've seen Steve Gadd lied before, but I never saw a Eric Clapton.
But anyways, it goes to that and then I go on, I listened to a,
yeah.
Oh, what the fuck do I live to do a couple of pretenders songs?
Then I get into Aerosmith's first fucking album and then I'm done.
Right. Just like that. I eased my way.
He is my way, you know, we start off really easy.
Then I get to mid range and then I just get to our Smith's first fucking want.
That's what I did because what I was doing before I was,
I was like regretting, like not regretting,
hating doing cardio and I was starting off with like fucking iron maiden or Dr
feel good. Do you know what I mean? Like that's not like if you're,
if you just waking up and you're getting on a fucking elliptical, it's all here.
Oh, is that the band?
Just like Jesus, Vince, Vince for fuck sakes.
Okay.
Well, he's got, at least I could start with home sweet home. Right.
And He'd know I'm a dreamer. Um,
you know, I just realized we have company upstairs.
Once I put the headphones on, I don't even fucking realize I don't give a shit.
So I was listening to that and like Iron Baden, you know,
it's just like creeps you out.
Like you fucking getting on an elliptical half groggy.
Cause I gotta go into work and Shit. Right. Starting your day off.
We want information, information,
information away. The new number two was number one.
You are number six, right? How about Vincent Price? I'll fucking work.
He got in the early eighties, man. He was fucking crushing it. Huh? Whoa.
Do you o F and c for the Devil's sends?
The beef was rad because he knows that diamond shot let him a lot understanding
record the number of the beast. 40 is a human number.
It's number is 666 a puppet to Baba two [inaudible] right.
He gets he and then he was on fucking Michael Jackson's thriller, right?
Yeah. No fucking crazy laugh in the end.
I can't remember the funk of 40,000 years.
I never really listened to Michael Jackson.
Like I was one of those people had way to like pretend to be sad when he died.
You know what I mean?
I'm looking back to bed in the mirror, you know,
share more data.
Right. It just never spoke to me. I like shit when he was a kid.
Okay.
Oh baby. Give me more and more chance. I liked right up to off the wall,
uh, somewhere. Uh, I dunno.
Yeah,
I guess I liked some, I liked some of, uh, like Billy Jean was okay.
Thrill I thought was stupid. You know, you know, it's actually thrill.
It isn't stupid. You know what it is. It's fucking, whenever it comes on,
everybody has to start doing the thriller dance and they always start with the
same thing where it's the claws up in the air on either side.
Always, always there.
Always somebody doing a fucking Michael Jackson impression, you know?
You know what's interesting about that guy is great as he wants the balls and
Pete to critique this man is like, he was one of those guys,
he had the sickest fucking dance moves and then he just stopped and he kept put
the loafers and he kept doing the leg thing and he kept rubbing his dick and
then everybody kind of caught up and went past him.
Even though he was still always the greatest dancer of all time. He, she was,
it was like he was doing the Charleston, his whole,
his whole fucking life bad to get through. He comes the Moonwalk,
right. Somebody can't even remotely fucking debts. Um,
oh, the fucking balls I'm showing on this podcast. Oh, let's keep going.
What other fucking legend can we keep? Can we trash next? Um, yeah.
I never got into a, I never get in. Like when they almost,
it was always like Prince First Michael Jackson. Like to me it was,
it was always prints. It wasn't even clothes.
And um,
I don't know.
Prince is funny because his bad songs always sound like songs that Molly
Ringwald would have danced around to win like 16 candles.
Okay.
Like he's got a couple of those. We just like Jesus.
I guess everybody's got those right and if he has one of those, Geez, Bill,
can you trash anymore? Dead Geniuses? Yeah, I can.
Let's go. Let's start talk.
Let's talk about Mark Twain and fucking Albert Einstein.
Is it me or do they both have this same fucking pipe?
What was it about being a genius back then or someone who was changing the way
people were thinking that you just, you had to have that fucking,
that same fucking do it with Sammy,
the Sammy Hagar and Van Halen. Fucking do. Except it was white. Right?
Mark Twain had it a fucking a Albert Einstein had it.
Frederick Douglas had that with that fucking itchy Baird.
Everybody had that when you fucking are just too goddamn smart.
You know what I mean? Like shit and I don't know.
You just got too much shit to think about.
There's something about that hairdo that just, it's just the perfect thing.
I bet. Sam looks back. I was like, why did, why did I cut my hair?
Like that was phenol. The haircut he got was like when he was younger,
when he had the longer hair. That's like the chick you marry.
And then like after she has a couple of kids and she just,
I just don't want to deal with it anymore.
He got like literally got that fucking hair cut, you know,
just short of, um, I, you said that you, you know,
are you moving towards an alternative lifestyle here?
Like what is going on with that thing? That was just a bad fucking period, Huh?
They were wearing those, those peach fucking flashdance fucking overalls.
Um, I dunno. All right.
Sammy Hagar.
I think San Diego would have been better if he didn't join van Halen. Oh,
I'm going after. I'm fucking, I'm talking about everybody this week.
I don't know what I'm doing here.
I think I'm going for fucking a reality show right now.
UV that song heavy metal by Sammy Hagar.
I liked that better. And you watch him performing with his own fucking,
I'm gonna fucking tweet that out.
Yeah,
I'm going to tweet that fucking video this week. You know what I mean?
You tell me that. Anything he did van Halen, not trash van Halen.
Cause I fucking love those guys.
But I'm just saying Sammy should've jumped in there. He should've kept going.
He was on a path. The man could not drive.
All right.
Tall [inaudible] heavy metal. Right. He was fucking great.
I don't know what happened then all of a sudden
I get that
right. I don't know what happened. I fucking voice is cracking. All right.
I think I've trashed enough people that are way, way,
way more talented than I'll ever be. So now it's time.
Now it's time to say goodbye to all you fucking counties.
I gotta I gotta read a little bit of advertising. Oh, and there's a lot that,
oh, a lot this week. Everybody piling on trying to get your holiday money,
trying to get that holiday money. Oh look who's back.
Look who's back. Always nosing around during the holidays, right?
Oh See, oh, Sherry's berries. Oh,
these things are fucking delicious. No matter who you're shopping for.
Sherry's berries is the one stop shop for everyone on your list.
No matter who you're shopping for. Sherry's berries is the one stop shop.
I read that twice.
You don't have to battle the crowds to get the perfect gift shop with
convenience right from your home Christmas. Um,
and it says example, only one week away. Now I have to do the math.
Christmas is only 20 days away, man.
So that's a, it's owning also. I already did the days you can't. All right.
What do you want to hear? They okay? It's, it's three weeks and four days away.
That's 25 days left to shop. Rapid. Deliver your gifts.
Choose a gift from Sherry's Barry's incredible collection of gifts.
And Go ahead and skip the crowds in the hassle altogether. Who to fuck it?
Somebody chocolate strawberries for Christmas.
The the don't get these for your wife unless you've got a nice fucking backup,
unless you put that on the hood of a fucking Toyota.
Cressida why I picked that one? I don't know. Um,
this is the perfect gift for someone that you have to acknowledge that you're in
your life, but you don't have time to shop for them or spend any fucking money.
Let's get down to brass tacks or this is a great accrued for mom for a really
great gift, okay? And it's fucking easily as easy as hell.
What are Sherry's berries?
They're freshly dip strawberries from Sherry's berries started just 1999 that's
over 30%. So it's a round a fucking drinks.
Unless you're in a shit hole that's over 30% savings or double the berries for
just $10 more. You can double them. 30 bucks.
You get twice as many berries.
They still haven't told me how many fucking berries I get.
You just need my code to take advantage of this deal.
Can I get Barry Manilow to sing in the background for Sherry's berries? Right?
I ate strawberries there.
Make the whole world sing descriptive words for berries.
Evidently I'm supposed to use these words. These strawberries are decadent,
fresh, juicy, sweet. I hate that word. Decadent.
It's always used by dumb people to describe something,
you know is a decadent like fucking something that's like ornate.
Another word I never fucking use. They really use decadent to disk. Oh,
have you tried these chocolate covered pretzels now? Are they any good?
Any good dude? They're decadent.
Alright, there you go. That's your challenge.
This weekend I want you to go to a dive bar and I want you to you,
I want you to describe something as decadent to a fucking barfly with no family
to go home to this holidays and I just want to say and please take a picture of
the look on the guy's face. All right.
Choose Barry's dipped and tempting white milk and dark chocolate.
Goodness y'all. Why the white come before the doc son top put chocolate chips,
decorative swizzles and chopped nuts. Any incredible unique gifts?
That's perfect. Oh, an incredible unique gift that's perfect for sharing,
Yada Yada to it. I don't have time to read all this shit.
Call to action with Christmas right around the corner.
There's only one way to get the amazing 1999 Sherry's berries deal.
Just visit Barry's, B e, r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone at the top of the right hand corner and Type in Berber
Cherries. Berries has something for everyone and every tastes.
Go to Barry's dot com click on the microphone and type in [inaudible] or to them
today. I'm gonna have to blow through this shit. [inaudible] me.
Andy's strawberries up your ass, but will do to me on days me on these.
That's where the chocolate factory is.
They rub up against your fucking balls.
It's like a horse muzzle wrapped in a rabbit ear. It's the softest shit.
Go Fuck yourself with God damn me undies. All right.
Picture a world picture in a world we're putting on a new pair of underwear
isn't just fresh. You're stepping into a better day.
Think about your balls or your clam underwear.
It's the best as the first thing you put on and the last thing you take off.
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey,
why would you settle for anything less than the best feeling underwear on the
planet? Mandy's focus,
so focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced. All right for price, the price at two fucking cocktails.
Munies will deliver your new pair of favor and underwear right to your doorstep.
Jesus Christ is in on somebody's index finger looking you creepy spinning it
around. Here's your underwear. A big boy. Better Day guaranteed. Try them on.
They're not the most comfortable, best feeling unease you ever had.
They'll refund your money and you get to keep the first pair for free.
These Uber Cozy undies are sold exclusively on the Mandy's website and where you
can enjoy free shipping in the U S and Canada.
Every other country can go fuck themselves. All right.
For a limited time hiccups,
everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL, [inaudible] dot com slash bar all right,
that's Mandy's dot com slash bar right now for 20% off your first order. Hey,
palm size.
Hmm.
All right. Now, of course,
now I'm trying to read fast and I'm getting the hiccups. All right,
these next two ones are short. Here we go. Tipsy elves, everyone.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater this time of year. If you want.
Bragging rights for the most talked about sweater, your Christmas party.
Listen up costs. Tipsy yells has hundreds of Christmas sweaters,
designs that are nothing like you've seen before.
They're not for the faint of heart. Check out all our new 2016 sweaters.
You won't find them anywhere else. Tipsy l sweaters are all about fun,
but are serious on quality and construction.
While you're shopping for your ugly sweater,
check out the yellow holiday and collegiate attire for yourselves or as a gift
like adult onesies,
adult onesies.
I've always wanted one of those with the trapdoor to take this shit out of.
All right for me, for men, interactive sweaters, beer pong, cornhole,
and Christmas suits for women holiday leggings. You fucking Hawaii cake.
When are they not whoring it up? Jesus Christ. Santa Claus is comedy.
He's an old man.
You're going to get my heart attack sweater dresses in pajamas right now.
My List is get 20% off tipsy tipsy elves.com on anything on the site.
Go to tipsy elves.com enter my code bird checkout for 20% why discounts?
That's tipsy elves.com and my cold. Alright, my code, my code.
All right, last one. And then back to the podcast. Simply safe. Everyone.
Thousands of people seeking home security get ripped off every day.
And uh,
and the home security industry wants you to believe it's your only option, man.
They got hoods of salesmen out there trying to scare the fuck out he into
signing one of those longterm contracts. You don't need that shit.
You get stuck writing huge checks month after month with no way out.
It's a robbery by contract and it can cost you a thousand,
but there's a better way to protect your home. Simply safe home security.
Oh my God, what's that? Simply safe has no contracts. None.
You get award winning 24, seven protection named best in the industry.
I don't know who that could have been.
Somebody at the company that didn't say who said it,
they just put quotes around it. A security professionals watching,
ready to instantly send the police. And it's just 1499 per month.
That's less than half of what most companies charge.
Protect your home the smart way. Why do they make peeping toms?
Just get into security. Then you kill two birds with one stone.
You know what I mean? They get to look in and they get their little heart on.
They rub it out into their fucking awful fucking security guard pants,
but they're also making sure that no one comes in the house. Right?
Would that work? I Dunno. Protect your home, the smart way.
Visit simply safe bird.com go to the right.
Go right now and get their free shipping on your order with a free key chain
remote. We're 25 bucks. It only takes a minute. That's simply safe.
bird.com simply safe.com [inaudible]. Why did I sit it wrong?
Simply say for, is it bird.com all right,
let's get to some of the questions here for this week. Hey,
did you guys see over in England there? They got the fucking
okay.
They got some shit that we would even make Snowden go. God Damn,
I didn't even think of that.
They got some stupid thing over there where they just going to everybody,
anything you do on your phone or on the internet or anything like that,
any of that shit, they can just look at it.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Okay.
It's unbelievable. Pope presidential election goes by.
They never talk about any of that shit. Why the fuck do you think that is? Oh,
fucking Obama, right?
He was in office when all that Snowden Shit went through the big fucking
liberal. All you pussies who cried when Hillary didn't get in.
You see what the fuck happened when Obama was in? Yeah.
Bunch of baby scuffs. So disappointed. Anyways, let's,
let's read some fucking shit here. Here we go. Advice on the future.
Dear Bill Murphy [inaudible] first of all, congrats on the kid. New,
special Yada Yada. Thank you.
I'm an 18 year old guy out of high school and need, need career advice.
I graduated with honors. Good for you. Straight A's, Jesus and all that crap.
But I currently don't attend college and I'm working some shit job in a pasta
factory. Sounds like you're burned out on the academics there. Um,
he's, oh, he said this is because what I really want to do
is sing parentheses classical shit,
take piano lessons and be happy. My dream isn't to be famous or anything,
but I love music and want to pursue it. Problem is I have zero background,
can't sing, can't play anything. Literally zero.
There's a great place nearby where I,
I lived that gives vocal and piano lessons and all I want to do is start
training my voice to start playing,
but I feel like there's no point because I have no experience.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. Dude, you know what it is. You're one of these people,
you get straight A's, you're an overachiever and you're so God damn smart.
Every time you come up with the option,
you know when the f the normal level of fear comes up,
smarties like you can come up with like,
rather than just 10 reasons not to do it,
you'll come up with a thousand and you're, you're,
you're paralyzed right now is what's going on. He said,
I spent my free, you're only 18 old dude.
You know, nobody has any experience till they till they start experiencing it.
You're already being way too hard on yourself. He goes, all right. He goes,
I spend my free time listening to countless covers of the same song,
watching videos on vocal exercises and fantasizing about being a singer one day.
I feel I can really do it sometimes,
but other times I feel like not even trying. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a, okay.
That first emotion where you feel like trying to do it,
you need to listen to that. That second one that talks you out of it.
You need to stop listening to that voice. You need to out loud.
Tell that voice to shut the fuck up. That's what I did.
I literally would talking to the, you gotta beat the fuck out of that voice.
That one that goes, Nah. Yeah, yeah, but what if this happened?
Nobody's going to like me. Sit down and shut the fuck up. All right.
I don't need you on this one. I need you. When I'm thinking about doing heroin,
then I need you going away. Well, if you get it [inaudible] you die.
You make everybody cry yet. Yeah. Then I'll listen to you.
But not when you're going after a dream.
You don't listen to any of that negative shit because you'll talk yourself out
of it. Um, anyways, I know you always preach about following your dream born.
It actually comes to doing it. It's very scary. Of course it is. However,
I don't want to be 40 years old and think, man,
what if my 99 year old aunt always tells me to do what I want and forget about
money, but my parents say that I need a real job. Well,
who has more life experience? Your 99 year old aren't and what does she say?
Huh? Your parents that too close to you, you know,
they're worried you're going to be homeless and all that shit.
So they're always going to say,
just get a fucking job so you can have enough money to put a roof over your head
and eat a sandwich. That's, that's all they're thinking of.
Nobody dreams of that.
Nobody dreams about just having a roof over their head and eating a sandwich.
Unless you're, I don't know, unless you live in some fucking squallor. Right.
But even then after a while, once you had the roof over your head,
then you're going to at some point be like, I want to do something right.
I don't know. Anyways, I've been in between for a year.
I've been in between for a year now and need help.
I don't want to get massively in debt for something I don't really want.
That is so fucking smart.
All these poor kids coming out of fucking college,
hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt at this fucking point,
or at least the high 10 thousands, you know,
that's why you love being a fucking moron, you know?
Cause then your community college doesn't cause shit. You work at Dunkin donuts,
throw a couple of coffees at people and all of a sudden you got money for your
next semester.
I'm maybe pursuing music will open doors to majoring in music in the future.
I Dunno. What should I do? You Pale Bitch. Ah,
ps give clearly a head scratch for me. Pitbulls are awesome. Um,
and he says Asian need advice from bill birth. Oh, that's the next person.
Is that it? Oh, all right. Yeah. You know what's fucked up? I was going to say,
Oh, you're Asian dude. You're going to crush the piano.
That's one of those stereotypes that I guess is racist,
but it's like positive racism. You know what I mean?
Don't take up the cello.
You'll be playing for your fucking major cities philharmonic.
All right? This is what I would do. Uh,
I would just start taking lessons immediately. I would sign up immediately.
I would not listen to the rest of this podcast. Hit Stop,
walk over to the phone, call the number and get a lesson as soon as you can.
Go to the lesson. Okay? And then keep going and,
and just see what that feels like. Don't stop BAFTA one. It'd be like, well,
I only went to one. I can't even play chopstick yet. Fuck this. Fuck that voice.
Keep going. All right. Just say,
I'm going to stick with this for three months. All right?
That's the big thing with it. With anything,
you gotta stick with it for three months and really work at it. Working out,
learning an instrument, learning a language. God knows I always end up quitting.
I can't even get fucking a hundred days together. Um,
just stick with it and see how you feel after three months.
If you feel like this isn't for me, you're not going to have that. Well,
what if, what if? Bullshit because you tried it so this isn't,
you're not making a decision that's going to affect the rest of your life.
Don't look at it like that. You just looking at the next three months,
the next three months are going to happen.
Do you want to after 90 days still be sitting there going,
I have no experience. I don't know what to do.
Working in a pasta place and you want to be in this fucking pasta place and you
know how to play a couple of songs. Dude, you be fucking excited man. A few.
If you actually, if this is what you really want to do,
you'll be at work thinking about it.
Can't wait to get home and play the fucking piano or,
or try my singing some songs or whatever. And then once you get that,
then that gets in your DNA and when you have stuff to look forward to in life,
all of a sudden shit that you don't look forward to,
you start looking at it like, why the fuck am I doing this? The sucks.
You know, I don't want to do this.
And then that gets you out of that and you start going down a path of what the
fuck you want to do.
Then the other side of that is then your whole fucking life is nothing but fun
shit. Then when you actually have to do shit that you don't want to do,
like go down to the fucking DMV and find the title for your Goddamn Prius,
right? Then you can be a big fucking baby about it. So there, there,
there's always a price to pay. But dude, that's what I would do. I would,
I would stop listening right now and sign up for those lessons and go in there
and just tell your teacher, so this is something I've always wanted to do.
I'm just nervous about it.
Just fucking just say what you said to me and they'll be like, hi. All right,
well let's, let's get you on that dude. You'd be fucking playing piano,
Bob. How easy it is to make a change in your life.
Just fucking pick up the phone,
say what you want to do and then when it's time you show up and you do it and
then you're doing it. You know, you just got to get around all those blocks.
So a, I hope you listen to me, man, cause you're only 18 years old,
so it's not like you have 50, 60, and even then,
I would still tell you to do it because who gives a fuck whether you get
anywhere with it. But if you want to do that, you know, you should do it.
All right. That's it for that. Okay.
Asia needs advice from Bill Burke. Bill,
I love your podcast and you really awesome. Um, Asian male, uh,
Chinese with squinty fucking eyes and can't drive for shit. Dude. You know,
kind of shit on yourself. Um, anyways, I need your advice.
I came to America, I guess I always do. I'm a Paul pasty con. Um, anyways,
I need your advice. I came to America a year ago and I really love tall,
slim Irish German girls with red hair. Jesus Christ.
I just missed, I just missed be in your fucking dreamboat.
I think they're beautiful. I'm a tall Liam. A blonde is beautiful too.
Never seen such beauty where I'm from. Holy Moly.
The problem is I'm not like tall and confident like white guys and I live in
Texas. Jesus Christ. Dude, this is a fucking reality show waiting to happen.
I tried to ask this redhead at the gym out and she won't take me seriously.
All right. Time the fuck out.
Dude hat off to you for the fucking balls you got.
You came here from China. You've learned the fucking language, right?
You're in Texas, you're at the gym. You're talking shit right.
Gives a fuck. You went up to the plate. You didn't get on base.
Who gives a shit? Talk to another red head. Talk to a blonde,
talk to whatever the fuck you want to keep talking to them. Say,
what do I need to do to data redhead? Now Jesus Christ.
Wait, because I'm a red head, like I know,
like there's some secret fucking handshake.
He said they want me to be their Asian friend, but I really want to marry him,
Bang them, and have cute kids. This driving me nuts. I mean,
am I going against nature?
Is an Asian guy dating white girls frowned upon and not accepted in America?
Thanks in advance. I don't really cuss that much and don't mean to offend you,
but uh, wanting to talk and act like you Jimmy Chow out.
Um, yeah. Okay.
His is Asian guys dating white guys found upon like everything is frowned upon
in every fucking country. Generally speaking,
people are afraid of anything fucking new. Who gives a shit?
Literally like that guy before me who said he wanted to play piano,
if he told somebody he wanted to do that, you know? Um,
I think initially people be encouraging or whatever. They'll always be,
there's always gonna be people telling you not to do shit.
Is this what you want to do sir? Yes. Then I would go out and do it. All right.
So it sounds like to me from your email that you've, uh,
you know, I don't know. It's like, it's like you just got into the majors. Okay.
It's the first week. You haven't gotten your first hit yet.
What are you going to do? You're just going to baseball.
Go back down to the miners. Fuck dead. Keep,
I would keep talking every time you hit on a woman, you get better at it.
All right. And I would just, I would just continue,
like you're doing everything you need to do. You go into the gym,
you stay in shape and you're talking shit. I mean, I don't, I don't,
I don't see anything wrong with your game plan other than, you know,
it hasn't happened for you yet. And um, this is something, uh,
you know, it's going to take a minute. You know,
if you can just walk up and talk to some chicken at the gym and get laid,
I mean, then everybody would be fucking doing it.
The reason why most people don't do it is because they know that 99.9% of the
time you're going to get the fucking Heisman. A Z easy.
This is my elliptical over here. This is your elliptical over there, right?
Fuck off. Right? And for all the women, they're going like,
can you just like not hit on us at the gym? Can you just fucking not,
can I just have this fucking place? Hey, they make gyms for that.
They make the all ladies fucking gems. All right,
the fuck you going to go? They're working out looking good.
And then you're upset that the guy's coming up and hitting on you
some day ladies, some days they're not gonna want to talk to you.
Take it from somebody, okay? Who? The women, they don't even,
they don't even like, you don't even like register.
Okay?
Like I'm, I'm like, I'm a fuck. I'm a sir.
I became a sir or mister like fucking 15 years ago and it's all
alright. Okay. Boyfriend's obsessed with video games.
Now I know somebody in seminary mill fucking,
they're gonna talk about some borderline sexual assaulting. Obviously,
that's not what I'm talking about.
I'm just talking about a little playful flirtation of someone who wants to fuck
you. Boyfriend's obsessed with video games.
How far into this podcast am I? All right,
this one's going to be a little bit short. I usually go a little over an hour,
but, uh, that's what I'm going to have to stop today cause uh,
I get to go into fucking why gotta go to [inaudible]. Um,
boyfriend's obsessed with video games. Hey Buffalo Bill.
I love your podcast and I'm a huge fan by boyfriend and I love a both.
Love to listen to your rants about whatever bullshit comes to mind. Uh,
I myself have add and can find myself rambling about something completely
different than whatever it was I started to ramble about. Anyway.
My boyfriend has always been a huge fan of video games and he can play them all
day if he could. Uh,
more recently he has been obsessed with one game in particular for the last
eight plus months and it's really put a strain on our relationship.
He will turn on his x-box from the second he gets home until about four hours
before he has worked the next morning. Jesus.
So we pretty much spend no time together and lets them,
unless it's me watching him play with his friends,
he talks to his friends while he plays online,
in which case even if I do say something to him,
he either doesn't hear me or just ignores me.
I've tried talking to him about it and he refuses to change or compromise.
It's even started to affect our sex life.
I imagine it would because he has no time for sexy time.
We are both still young and in our late twenties and I hate that I'm practically
begging him to turn off the game.
Sweden canoodling the sheets I've been contemplating just breaking off our
relationship of five plus years because it's been this way for months and it has
only gotten worse. I'd love to hear what the Wise Nir has to say as well.
Thanks for all the good laughs and congratulations on both of use on the new
baby birth. Thank you. Um, unfortunately Nias not here.
Let me see if I can get her, hold on one second. Okay.
She's on her way down. Um, I would say first of all,
you've been together for five plus years. Um,
initially my first thought when you were doing this is what I would do if, if,
what would get make me pay attention is I would just start going out with your
friends and just start wearing fucking sexy outfits and shit.
And he'll get the message immediately.
If you walk out the door looking good and he's sitting there fucking playing
video games and stuff and he, if he doesn't get that hint, then yeah,
you gotta be thinking like, well, what the f this guy is just,
this guy's more interested in this shit than that.
What I'm doing over here with my fucking Christmas leggings going out to a
Christmas party dress like a fucking hot piece edge.
[inaudible] that's what the fuck I would do.
You've already tried to talk to them. Um, I gotta be honest with you.
I understand people becoming obsessed with video games.
It's why I don't play them. But to me this, I, I'm a,
I'm a bit of a cunt when it comes to video games. To me that's a child activity.
You know what I mean? It's like what is this person working towards?
What do they have for a fucking job that come home from their job and they just
play a video game for the whole fucking rest of the day does not sound like a
driven man. Um, that's another fucking red flag.
Um, so that's what I would, I would just start building a life.
Initially I would start building a life without him to see if he notices and
maybe you guys can get back to where you were or if he doesn't notice,
then you already have a head start on getting the fuck away from this guy.
So the lovely Nia is here. I'm going to hit pause a letter. Read this email, um,
or Nia want, if you just want to,
if you could just read this while I continue to ramble here. Uh,
it starts right here. My boyfriend's been a fan of the video games. Okay. Yada,
Yada, Yada, knowledge shit. So that's, that's basically a,
that's what I would do. And as I mentioned a long time ago,
the last video game that I played was grand theft auto three,
and it literally consumed my life. I would be walking
okay
to the comedy clubs getting on a boat and I would be thinking about the game
when I wasn't even a, I wasn't even at home.
I'd be waiting to go on stage thinking about, okay, you know,
I'll finish this set and I'll go home and I'll,
I'll use the cheats and I'll just go on a fucking rampage and all that shit.
And it just kind of took over my life. So here's the lovely Nia with her advice.
Oh,
um,
first of all, can I just say that this problem really sucks and um,
it's really annoying and that you're both in your 20s and he's like addicted to
playing video games. I'm sorry,
but that's a lame ass and you need to move on. Seriously.
Five years, five plus years.
It's been this way for months and it's only gotten worse. Yeah.
You said you tried to talk to him about and he refuses to change or compromise?
Well it's just, yeah. And he obviously his priorities for this video game,
I don't know if he,
is there something else going on and your relationship or did he have some kind
of
yeah,
something bad happened recently that he doesn't want to deal with or something
and that's why he's so consumed by the video games.
Cause I'm just trying to think like what normal healthy, happy person.
Just all of a sudden he didn't want to bang his broad yeah.
And hands over his life to a video game.
Like I feel like something happens and he's not able to like what you talked to
client legal. Okay. Cause you're sticking it in
my face like, well cause you do this, he started talking all the way.
I'll be hand that people can't hear you. Oh okay. Going at the levels. Yeah.
All right. I'm so sorry. That's all right.
Um, yeah, I, I would not necessarily say less listen,
it's the video games or May,
but you can just say something along those lines of like, listen,
I feel like I'm not a priority in your life.
And if that's the case then we really need to talk about this relationship.
Cause if you're not into it,
then just let me go so I can find somebody who was into me and it's gonna pay
attention to me and not their x box.
This is what I was saying she should do.
She should just fucking dress like a whore and go out that night and just see if
he notices like just to have like fucking, you know,
fucking sty highs on and all that shit. If he doesn't get it then my highest.
Yeah, just dress like a fucking whore. I highs their stockings,
they go up to your thighs and then they stop and there's this glorious little
fucking hint of leg.
You're so old that you feel like women are going out and like thigh high.
It's like they're like saloon mistresses like on Westworld. Why?
Cause I came of age in the 18 hundreds why you guys?
Why you acting like you guys don't always whore it up every fucking holiday
you'll hoard up on your birthday. You're hoard up on Halloween.
You're hoard up on Christmas sex. It's called being sexy. Sexing it up.
[inaudible] it up when you're coram on the fucking head bladder.
That's what you guys do. It's different to be titties out.
Clam peeking out from it.
No, cause I don't,
I don't believe in that passive aggressive shit that's just like, listen mother,
fuck are you into this or not? Because if not then I need to move on.
The thing is though, honey, he has made his choice.
That's what I think that you don't necessarily want to fully admit to.
He's made his choice.
He's more interested in the video game for whatever reason he won't talk about
it. He won't compromise. He's made his choice.
Maybe he's not into the relationship anymore.
Is that a possibility?
Is it a possibility that he maybe she needs to or it up.
She's saying she's like trying and she's trying to like beg him to,
to even have sex, which is ridiculous.
It could be that he is just not into the relationship anymore and he's such a
fucking pussy ass puss that he's waiting for you to be the one to dump him
because a lot of people do that. A Pussy Hess plus I don't even know.
But you know some people are,
they don't want to be the bad guy or they're just immature and cowardly so they
don't want to say, listen,
I think we should break up because they feel guilty cause it's been five plus
years.
So they do shit like this to like make you be the one to break up with them
because they're cowards. You know what I mean? So it is possible to,
in conclusion, what do you say? I'd say dump his ass by.
There you go. That's all right. See that? All right.
Now you want to listen to me read out loud. Oh God. I know.
This would be hilarious is a fucking baby realizes that I'm not good at reading.
What age do you think they're going to be fucking turnaround panel?
Look up at me like mommy doesn't sound like this and you'll be
good at reading like children's stories. All
right. I walked into that one. All right. Here's some adult advertising.
Ladies. It's the holiday season and you know what that means. It's time.
No kidding. MVMT watches movement.
We get it. Holiday shopping can be tough.
I don't like it so we get it like I'm already bitching. I'm not,
or I think it's the readers. We get it. Holiday shopping can be tough.
Yeah, it's more sympathy.
It's not hostility which that's your default emotion is hostility.
This is more of a we. Yeah, we understand. Okay. Any excuse to trash bill.
I see how it works now.
I played the victim just like Paul Simon with something goes wrong.
I'm the first to admit it and the last one didn't know. Oh Paul,
let's work on your problems. Pauly. Hey Paulie.
What do you got going on there? That was here. Plugs. Is that a wig?
Does that Como moving watches all that gift. Gift-Giving.
Anxiety can disappear with the press of a button.
These watches make the perfect purchase for just about anyone in your life,
guy or girl,
and remember they started only $95 you have heard me talk about movement watches
and I am sure you got one yourself. Now let's finish your holiday shopping.
Get Movement watches for somebody on your list. This is great moving.
Watch this. Just start at 95 bucks at a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 classic design, quality construction,
and styled in minimalist style minimals over 500,000 watches sold over 160
countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns going by going to movement
watches.com/burr this watch has a really clean design and now is the time to
step up your watch game. Go to movement, watches.com/bar join the movement.
All right, plow through these last two here. All right.
Oh our old friends dollar shave club. Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing,
affordable raises right to your fucking door kid every month.
So you can get a great shave,
but raises aren't the only thing you need in the bathroom.
What about other shower stuff? Right? You want to paint your tank,
they got the right colors for you. Doesn't matter your skin color.
So that's the run. Fucking copy. Turns out dollar Shave Club got it right?
They came out with a new line of shower products,
shampoo and body wash called the wanderer. Well, lamb,
the Tampa guy who likes to wash his nuts.
The fragrances are unlike anything on the market. Is that mango? Yes.
Suchan there's subtle and actually smell like real natural ingredients.
There are a lot of body washes out there that make you smell like a teenager.
What does a teenager smell like? Hope. Um,
this mint and Cedar Wood bought mint in Cedar Wood.
Bodywash is amazing and makes you smell incredible.
Mint in Cedar Ward. That's like your dropped ice cream and like a fucking sauna.
Dante, you don't,
you sit in those little cedar wood things right before the naked Asian guy comes
in. Not American, Asian,
Asian, Asian, uh, you've got to give it a try. Once you're in the club,
you'll see the pro. The products work amazingly, the services world-class.
There's no longterm commitments, no hidden fees,
and you can cancel whenever you want.
And Best of all that giving away a one month trial of any of their fucking
raises for a dollar with free shipping, I'm af.
And after that it's just a few bucks a month. Get you one day,
blah blah blah blah blah. At Dollar Shave club.com/ [inaudible] that's delish,
slave shave club.com/burr. And lastly, but not leastly wait a minute,
is it meant and cedar wood,
like there are two different fragrances. That's right.
It is Cedar Wood and Cedar Wa.
Just like peanut butter and jellies. Just to be clear,
one sentence meant in one sentence, Cedar Wood.
I thought it was like peanut butter and jelly or Turks and Caicos. Yes. Builded.
No. That Turks and Caicos was an actual place that is the worst name ever.
He said Turks and Caicos as if you could believe Turks or Kinkos but not turns
and cage. The word and that you have and in your country,
United States of America and Utah.
Like why would you say that? And Puerto Rico.
All right. Stamps Com with the holidays almost here,
you don't have time to go to the post office. It will be packed with everyone.
Mailing holiday gifts and packages. So what are your, do you use stamps.com yet?
Dumb fuck with stamps.com you can avoid all the hassle man and going to the post
office during the Polish, the busy holiday season,
everything you would do at the post office you can do right from your desk
except expose yourself in public buy and print official US postage using your
own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or package the instant you need it.
Then the mailman picks it up and on. I evidently, I use stamps, ace. I do.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters.
Trust me if I can do what you can to, I'm a moron. So it's that easy right now.
Uh, I can,
I can get you a better offer from stamps.com than what's on the homepage.
Sign up@stamps.com use my last name,
bird to get a four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes the postage
and a digital scale. Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstamps.com enter Berg. Guess what,
folks? That's the podcast for this week's, this week's this week.
And I gotta get the Fuck Outta here cause I got to go to work.
Gotta go edit and it edited and it's so, uh, uh, that's it.
Go fuck yourselves. And I will check it on. Yeah. On Thursday.